and as soon as he switched from selling
newspapers to selling masks
uh in manufacturing he went from a few
million dollars a year
to a few million dollars a week
what's going on everyone what i want to
talk to you about today is a question
that i get
all the time which is how do i know i
have a good market
right which is what are the things i
should be looking for to know i have
a market that i should go after and the
first thing i wanna address here is you
know i had this conversation yesterday
and someone's like hey i'm between uh
you know uh
you know dentists and hearing aid
specialists and pharmacists right
for what market i wanna go after and
serve right and i was like okay
cool well what are the considerations
right and they didn't know how to
actually analyze each of those
businesses
and so the first rule of thumb that i'll
give anyone
is as long as the market is not dying
and is either normal or growing
then which of the markets can you
provide the most value to
all right so most value and that's given
your skill set
so if you have an advantage inherently
or you have experience
working with people in a specific
marketplace or especially if it's
personal experience
then i would usually recommend going
after that market first because you know
their pains
you know what it feels like you will
empathize with them and you ultimately
create a better product that will
provide more value to them
and you'll be able to win now that's a
great scenario but many people i talk to
have basically no experience in any
market
and i'm like okay well then these are
the four things that i look for
all right so they are as follows
the first thing that i'm going to look
for is is the market
in pain all right so do they have a
desperate need
for my product or services right a nice
to have is not something people are
going to take their money out and buy
especially
in a bad economic condition right if
we're in a good economic time when
you're watching this and that's awesome
and if we're in a bad one then you'll
know right so the first thing i'm
looking for is do they have a desperate
need
are they starving for the thing that i'm
looking for right there are some things
that are timeless
right health wealth and relationships
are the timeless needs of humanity
right uh you know are they are they sad
and lonely that's relationships
uh are they broke that's always pain and
uh
health are they are do they feel bad
about how they look and are they
unhealthy right
and so those are three big ones right
but is there key pain that i'm solving
the second is is the market growing
right so i'll give you an example of
this
uh i think i've told the the story of my
buddy who owned the newspaper company
uh he could not figure out why his
company was not growing
um and he called me up and i was like
dude like you're much smarter than i am
uh it's probably because you're selling
the newspapers he's like no no it can't
be that and i was like
no i think it's that and as soon as he
switched from selling newspapers to
selling masks
in manufacturing he went from a few
million dollars a year
to a few million dollars a week all
right same entrepreneur
simply applied it to a growing
marketplace
all right the the next thing that i'm
looking for
in terms of marketplace is
are they easy to find all right and this
is important
because if you're marketing
and you can't find your prospects if i'm
marketing to plastic surgeons for
example and the only people seeing my
ads are nurses
then i'm not going to be able to get my
my my product my service
in front of them or even get my offer to
them if they're impossible to find
and so whenever i'm picking a market i'm
going to try and find one
that i can easily target uh that has
associations
they have groups they have channels they
all watch they're all congregated in one
place
and so that way i can cast my fishing
line there and then i can hook the
clients that can take a step up towards
me
because if you can't find them they'll
never find you right and so
one they have to be in pain two they
have to be growing
three they have to be easy to find all
right now the fourth one is purchasing
power
all right which is do they have the
monies right
now a quick example of this is i had a
friend of mine who was looking at this
and he was like
dude i've got the perfect market i'm
going after unemployed people
and i want to coach them on how to do
their resumes right tons of pain on not
having a job
he said it's definitely growing because
people are coming in and out of the
market so there's tons of people that
are coming in outside
my ads won't get fatigued and i was like
okay he's like they're super easy to
find and i was like that's great
but then he's like no one wants to buy
my stuff because they all say they don't
they don't have jobs
and so he wasn't able to have the
purchasing power
from this target right and so let me
give you an example of of
of two different ways that you could use
this framework right so let's say if i
were a relationship coach i was somebody
who serves uh
couples i'm good at helping people find
love right
well i'm gonna look for a market that
has all four of these things
which means instead of saying i'm gonna
help you know college kids
right for me my service business
find love all right instead of having
that's a heart
college kids find love what i would
probably do is instead
go after seniors right
in maybe their second half of life to
find their next
partner um that would probably be where
i was focusing
and what happens there is seniors have
tons of pain because they're alone
it's growing because people die and get
older every day right they're easy to
find
and i know that senior citizens in
general have far more money than college
kids though
right and so even though i have the same
core value proposition
i'm choosing to serve a better market
that i will ultimately probably make
more money with all right and so this is
kind of the process that i look at
is number one above all else which
market can i provide the most value to
if i have personal experience that's
going to trump
everything now if i don't have personal
experience and i just have a skill of
being able to market or sell or whatever
then i'm going to look at my market in
these in in this
four four piece system whatever you want
to say checklist
and the thing is is you can't just have
three of them right uh in the in the
newspaper example they were in tons of
pain they were easy to find
and they had purchasing power the
problem is they weren't growing they
were shrinking every year
right uh the the the unemployment
example
they were growing they were in pain but
they didn't have the purchasing power
so that's the that's the problem there
uh the nurses and
plastic surgeons example that would be
one or if i can't find them then i can't
display the ads to them
and then obviously if people don't want
your product at all
and it's just a nice to have then they
will not buy it all right and so
you want to make sure that you do not
have one two three of these you want to
have all four in any market you pick and
ideally
pick a market that you already know you
can provide value to and solve a problem
that meets these four criteria
and you'll have the recipe for success
so i hope that made sense that's how i
look at markets that's what i look at
when i'm trying to invest in companies
i look at the founder i see if they
already have experience in this and then
i see if the problem that we're solving
matches these things
and then at that point i say you know
what i think this is a good opportunity
let's do it
hope you enjoyed that and uh see you the
next video
[Music]
[Applause]
you